[Musique]
et avant de recevoir mon prochaine
invitée mélanie poquet et sur ce plateau
bonsoir on sort pour votre chronique
coup de coeur culture et on innove un
peu on va écouter tout de suite en
extraire
[Musique]
j'ai mal au monopole de la zambie j'en
serais j'attends les mots s'envolent
[Musique]
alors vous aurez sans doute reconnu à
106 milliards après un an d'absence le
groupe de grenoble remonte sur scène
mélanie et ce sera samedi lors de la
tournée les watts et sinsemilia c'est
même la tête d'affiché du festival alors
le 8 juin les équipes de metas vous
attendent pour pas moins de dix heures
de concert groupes et artistes vont se
relayer durant l'après-midi la soirée et
une partie de la nuit à voisin de buts
ces voix-là pouvoir proposer des têtes
d'affiché françaises ou internationales
la scène indépendante est également de
favoriser voilà la diffusion des groupes
émergents à du territoire on est encore
sur un petit fil rouge de cette année
dans le même style que l'édition
précédente
donc on va retrouver de la musique
reggae dub hip hop électro alors la
nouveauté cette année c'est le petit fil
conducteur c'est l'esprit punk mais du
punk mélanie avec un groupe au style
bien particulier
si on veut jouer sur les clichés on peut
parler du punk qui sont les endroits
mais plus sérieusement les ramoneurs de
menhirs c'est un groupe breton très
festif sur scène on retrouvera aussi
gérard baste qui est membre du groupe
des spin 4
alors quelques artistes que vous avez
cité le front dix ans tout à se succéder
la tournée les ouates cherche aussi à
sensibiliser et oui très sélectif
toilettes sèches très animé en général
ça fait l'animation gobelets
réutilisables papier recyclé et pour
vous déplacer jusqu'au site pourquoi ne
pas favoriser le covoiturage ou le vélo
et toutes les informations sont à
retrouver sur le site du festival
merci mélanie pour cette chronique on
vous retrouve bien sûr après ce journal
aux commandes de votre émission le 7-8
culture